[Musica]
Buonasera Buonasera a tutti e a tutte
Mazza quanti siete Fantastico Allora il
mio è un lavoro di merda Sostanzialmente
perché parlo con i politici e già questo
uno scusi sindaco dov'è Non vedo non
vedo nulla
parlo con i politici ma non ci parlo
diciamo come come avviene in televisione
come siamo abituati Purtroppo ad
assistere in televisione ormai da
diversi anni da tantissimi anni
noi cerchiamo di approfondire di mettere
in difficoltà di Porre un vero e proprio
contraddittorio Infatti a fine diretta
ogni volta mi chiama l'ufficio stampa io
Ma che cazzo è successo con l'onorevole
Ecco abbiamo avuto Renzi Conte letta la
l'ex ministra Azzolina ma non soltanto
questo Noi ci occupiamo anche di
approfondimenti Perché a questo In
realtà che mi ha fatto diciamo decidere
di iniziare questo percorso sul web
quindi prima su Twitch e poi anche su
YouTube ovvero il tema
dell'approfondimento con i dati alla
mano Prima abbiamo visto insomma i dati
sulla natalità o molto apprezzato
quell'intervento quando si parla di dati
È sempre un piacere Per quanto mi
riguarda purtroppo i talk show
l'informazione il giornalismo in Italia
non non va avanti con con i dati con gli
studi scientifici bensì
stendono tappeti rossi come questo qui
che questo calpestando io il più delle
volte e si cerca sempre lo scandalo lo
scontro la famosa polarizzazione
è per questo che ho deciso all'inizio
della pandemia di far nascere questo
progetto che in realtà è mutato molto
nel corso di questi due tre anni alla
fine è molto giovane però è già appunto
cambiato in diversi aspetti Io ho
pensato ho iniziato da grillino da
lettore del MoVimento 5 Stelle quindi
giustizia lista critico con l'Unione
Europea
super a favore della
politica di Giuseppe Conte all'inizio
Dopodiché mi Sono circondato ho avuto la
fortuna e anche un po' la lungimiranza
di circondarmi di persone che appunto
con i dati con studi scientifici con
approfondimenti ne hanno fatto una
carriera e di conseguenza sono riuscito
a cambiare a vedere il mondo da un'altra
prospettiva e secondo me in meglio poi
ovviamente ognuno su questo ha la sua
opinione Non esiste l'oggettività
E allora perché nasce appunto la miniera
nasce Proprio per per cercare di andare
a scalfire quella che è l'informazione
dei media tradizionali dei giornali
della stampa cartacea dei Talk Show a
cui siamo abituati Insomma ad assistere
dalla Rai Mediaset Sky La7 senza fare
distinzioni Ovviamente per fortuna
qualcuno si salva Ci mancherebbe altro
Non sono qui a fare il processo alla tv
e al giornalismo italiano però il più
delle volte siamo abituati ormai a
basarci su titoloni che ci fanno aprire
l'articolo e poi magari neanche lo
andiamo a leggere l'articolo o se lo
leggiamo troviamo tutt'altro i famosi
titoli clickbait la condivisione anche
spesso di fake news
ora i social ci hanno molto aiutato in
questo ovviamente perché hanno permesso
a tantissime altre persone di accedere
alle informazioni e anche di farla
pagine Instagram Twitter tiktok Facebook
appunto YouTube Twitch chi più ne ha più
ne metta questa ovviamente è stato un
bene per per il nostro paese in generale
per l'informazione Però è stato anche un
male da un certo punto di vista perché
non tutto ovviamente oro quel che
luccica quindi il mio consiglio
spassionato è quello di andare ad
ascoltare sempre più fonti non basiamoci
mai su una singola Fonte anche se è
quella che magari ci sembra più
veritiera che magari rispecchia il
nostro parere lì per lì Cerchiamo sempre
di andare a scavare più nel profondo ed
è per questo ripeto che nasce la miniera
per cercare di andare ad approfondire
tematiche complesse che troppo spesso
vengono banalizzate come per esempio la
pandemia stessa un esempio lampante
abbiamo visto come globalizzato il
dibattito negli studi televisivi dove
venivano invitati i personaggi
grotteschi personaggi che non hanno
veramente nulla da dire rispetto a una
cosa scientifica a una cosa legata alla
medicina
Giuseppe Povia con tutto il rispetto che
cazzo ci azzecca con i vaccini coil non
si sa però l'abbiamo ascoltato più volte
durante la pandemia stessa cosa
l'abbiamo ritrovata anche con la guerra
in Ucraina sempre a banalizzare Io sono
antiamericano quindi non mi schiero con
l'Ucraina Io sono con l'Ucraina Quindi
tutti i russi sono cattivi Questa è la
polarizzazione ma nel mezzo c'è molto di
più ci sono tantissime sfumature Non può
essere tutto bianco e tutto nero ed è
per questo che occorre approfondire
perdiamo un po' di tempo in più perdiamo
un po' di tempo in più a studiare a
parlare di quello che appunto ci
circonda temi economici temi di salute
temi storici
temi di ogni tipo vanno approfonditi non
si può banalizzare tutto a un semplice
titolo di giornale Questo è quello che
la televisione di fatto ha fatto in
collaborazione con la politica no anche
la politica stessa si è mossa in questa
direzione se ci fate caso al giorno
d'oggi i politici si muovono sul sentore
dell'opinione pubblica Abbiamo assistito
al DL Rave per esempio no dove c'era
questo scandalo di questo Rave
un'emergenza incredibile riuniamo tutti
i politici per fare il DL Rave
un'emergenza veramente
gigantesca poi abbiamo avuto Purtroppo
una delle tante tragedie legate
all'immigrazione emigranti Cutro stessa
cosa Il governo corre di L Cutro adesso
più di recente un fatto che mi ha
toccato particolarmente quello del
gruppo di youtubers The Borderline
qualcuno li avrà sentiti che a Casal
Palocco pare abbiano causato Insomma un
incidente o comunque siano stati
complici di un incidente che ha portato
alla morte di un bambino di 5 anni il
piccolo Manuel io quando ho letto quella
notizia mi sono messo a piangere in
diretta vi dico la verità un figlio di
un anno e questa cosa mi ha toccato
molto però l'articolo 27 della nostra
Costituzione dice che bisogna essere
garantisti fino alla fine ok Quindi non
basta una semplice accusa e lì il
giornalismo italiano ha fatto vedere la
parte peggiore titoli di giornale con
scritto youtuber assassini youtuber
uccidono bambino potrebbe essere andata
così probabilmente però le indagini sono
ancora in corso Ci deve essere un
processo ci devono essere delle condanne
definitive bisogna avere pazienza e qui
arriviamo all'altro grande dilemma dei
social che è quello della Gogna
mediatica non abbiamo la pazienza di
attendere che si porti diciamo a
conclusione un'indagine e un processo
siamo sempre pronti lì a trovare il
capro espiatorio strada da condannare Ma
neanche con spirito critico proprio con
insulti pesanti io stesso di recente
sono finito all'interno di una
cosiddetta shitstorm sui social per
diciamo un'uscita superficiale infelice
che ho avuto Perché quando si è esposti
mediaticamente ogni giorno può capitare
ovviamente di dire delle cazzate Io ne
ho detta una sull'incesto e sono stato
giustamente punito però non giustifico
quelli che sono arrivati a dire cose
pesanti Mettendo in mezzo mio figlio
minacce di morte Dovresti andare nei
Gulag queste sono cose che non possono
essere tollerate Non è vero che chi
lavora sui social deve essere abituato a
questo non dovrebbe funzionare così
e quindi da un certo punto di vista io
inviterei a provare un po' più di
empatia verso le persone sotto questo
punto di vista quindi il social è un
mezzo potentissimo di informazione ma è
anche molto pericoloso quindi dobbiamo
imparare ad utilizzarlo un'altra delle
storie che mi ha colpito di più In
questi giorni è quella relativa al
sommergibile Titan rispetto Magari
alle barche appunto di migranti che
purtroppo insomma anche in questi giorni
nelle acque greche si sono rovesciate
facendo morire un sacco di persone Ecco
l'informazione è questa purtroppo
cercare sempre la polarizzazione di
dividere le masse in due schieramenti
che poi si vanno a scannare l'un l'altro
quando in realtà si parla di due cose
ben distinte io possa essere solidale
verso I migranti trattare il tema
dell'immigrazione con serietà perché è
un tema serio senza però andare a
mancare di rispetto a 5 persone che nel
bene e nel male comunque hanno perso la
vita
ed è giusto Comunque rispettare anche
chi le sta piangendo in questo momento
sono esseri umani
poi ciliegina sulla torta l'ultima
diciamo questione che mi ha
particolarmente toccato in questi due
anni e che ho trattato moltissimo con
tanti esperti è stata la guerra in
Ucraina che è tuttora in corso Tra
l'altro vi do piccolo spoiler magari
qualcuno l'avrà letto ma in questo
momento c'è in corso una guerra civile
praticamente in Russia con uno dei
Generali Insomma che era impegnato nella
guerra in Ucraina che ha deciso di
lasciare l'Ucraina per andare ad
attaccare Mosca Qualcuno avrà sentito
parlare della Wagner Il gruppo appunto
comandato da questo generale prigogin E
lui adesso sta andando in Russia quindi
per dire Insomma ci siamo concentrati
tanto sul capire perché in Ucraina non è
giusto mandare delle armi in questo caso
ma in realtà insomma la soluzione ce
l'avevamo molto più vicina un popolo che
ha attaccato un altro Popolo
e ha costretto a milioni di persone ad
abbandonare la propria casa
forse qualche errore l'ha fatto Ecco io
capisco l'anti-americanismo capisco
tutto quello che volete Però stiamo
parlando di milioni di persone che sono
state costrette a lasciare la propria
casa per andare Chissà dove con i carri
armati sotto casa che hanno iniziato a
bombardarli e questo diciamo è un po'
uno dei temi che mi ha fatto incazzare
veramente tanto in questi due anni
perché in televisione è stato dato
spazio a personaggi senza competenze è
vero che ogni opinione legittima perché
siamo in democrazia Ma non è vero che
ogni opinione ha lo stesso valore un
professore di relazioni internazionali
un militare uno storico quando parla di
guerra conta di più a più valore quello
che lui dice rispetto a un sociologo o a
un professore di fisica non
dimenticatevelo mai io vi ringrazio e
buona continuazione
[Applauso]